and i look at like say the the leak from
what is the the uh supreme court
and then you look at it it's like
it's you look at the the the
articles that have been written about
this they say oh they took a vote and
it's already been
you wouldn't would think that they've
already overturned roe v wade no it was
a draft opinion by the supreme court of
the united states and it was leaked and
that was enough to spark all of this
conversation that we're having right now
of course and there's a threat that it
might happen so but it's not even that
it's the it's the supreme court taking
it away from the federal government and
putting it into the states and making it
state state by state which is why you
get other companies like
amazon and you get uh what is it
microsoft and tesla starbucks are saying
hey don't worry ladies we got you we got
you fam right if you're in an abortion
state they're already predicting that
this is going to should these
corporations stay out of the abortion
women are the biggest consumers well
there no it's even worse than that
because these the ladies if you think
that this is a good thing or like
starbucks has got your back or amazon or
whoever they don't have your back
because it's cheaper to give you three
or four thousand dollars to go and have
you cross state lines have an abortion
in an abortion state and come back and
stay employed at that particular
business than it is for you to get
pregnant or reload quit your job and
relocate to those states because you
want to be in an abortion state because
if you think about the community
employee retention is what their focus
is think about the cost so when a woman
gets pregnant that's the number one
reason why women quit the workforce
because they got the baby right and then
damn let's just talk about that for a
second and then corporations are looking
at their bottom line they're they're in
their personal
friends
they are lying rolo is dropping some
truth bombs out there
so it's a it's a it's an economic
decision if you want to talk about
economics
are we going to steer this that way um
that's the that is the reason why these
these companies are putting this out
there right now because it's also firing
you know get to the get to the polls
ladies but it's um it's cheaper for a
company to maintain and keep those it's
like egg freezing like what is it i
think facebook or fortune 500 they allow
you to freeze your eggs that's part of
the benefit benefit package for like
middle management and um you can freeze
your eggs they don't want you to breed
they want you to be informed i want you
to keep working keep working right
now i really want to add some of that
oh sorry go ahead i was just gonna say
with that said
doesn't it financially make sense for
our country to drive men and women apart
from a taxpayer perspective yeah it
absolutely does why is that well if you
have a family
and you have a strong man in the family
more than likely the woman's gonna stay
home and raise that baby instead of work
yeah so why don't we just nip it in the
blood and divide them
so and there's there's a lot of economy
tied up with we have twice the taxpayer
options now yeah you know so why don't
we go ahead and drive men and women
apart and and go ahead and get rid of
that nuclear family would you say that's
a map i would say so and i'd say we were
already on the way there i think i
mentioned this once before this morgan
stanley did their uh i think was 2019
when they did the uh was the rise of the
she economy and it's the it was a
message and was a whole thing that was
done for investors and that one of the
pro the projections that they made was
that women between the ages of 25 and 44
would be single 40 42 or 45 of women by
2030 would be single and childless in
that demographic and they're already
making projections for that so that like
guys can go okay well i'm going to plan
my business plans around this because
there's going to be more single women so
and the joke is of course you know
invest in like boxed wine and chewy or
chewy exactly but it's more than that
you can all but imagine what you would
do if you would invest in cryogenic oh
ovum freezing right you want to take it
to another like if you want to invest
and to forget chewy look into like uh
egg freezing company look into anything
well anything that promotes sort of like
fear of missing out for women of course
but also anything that promotes the idea
that women have longer than they do to
actually have to be to reproduce to have
a baby to have to you know fertility
that those kinds of investments going
forward according to morgan stanley
would be wise investments for people who
are putting money into the market yeah
uncle rollo drops the truth bob's hope
you guys are listening ladies i really
want to get your perspective here would
you like to hear would you go fast or do
you want to go tori i was gonna say what
rolo said of the she economy thing and
60 of women are in universities now why
wouldn't you cater to them they're
they're gonna be your workers the men
there's less of them there so the
corporations are more concerned about
these and these women working not having
kids not raising babies stay working
girl we'll pay for your abortion because
it's a lot cheaper than well they're
paying for a head hunter bringing on
onboarding new uh talent recruiting all
that they want us to do both remember
that because of our birth rates they
want us
they want us to do both they're getting
rid of abortions okay but
i don't know it just feels like we're
slaves who's they want us to do both the
corporations corporations clearly want
us to have abortion they're paying for
abortions no they don't want us to have
abortions well they don't want you to
have kids oh i thought they wanted us to
have kids no no that's the whole point
they're paying for abortion they're
paying for abortions to go no i know the
corporations but i'm saying the whole
like controversy is that they're getting
rid of ro rowan wade which means to
allow it to go in per state so a state
can decide if they want to have it or
not but i'm saying it was before that
abortions were legal federally right so
it still is right right right but i mean
certain states are taking over yeah and
in the future if they get rid of it okay
now women are gonna have to have the
babies which is fine if they're in a
non-abortion state that is right but
let's say that they all follow suit or
something like on the extreme end but i
don't know so it's like they want us to
have babies they want us to also be in
the workforce
i don't know that's completely final
final thoughts on abortion go ahead give
us your two cents um my final thoughts
is that i think everyone should do what
is best for their life
what if it's like nine months long um do
you think it's murder
i do think it's murder yeah i think most
americans see after a certain point that
it's murdered i think it's yeah pretty
much accepted the third trimester hell
no
you can do that
that's it the baby has a heartbeat and
i think that's can i ask you can i ask
you a question then yeah because i asked
this of matt walsh and he still hasn't
i'm still waiting for the call matt
if you if you think if you think that
abortion is murder i'm not trying to put
you on spot because you're not the first
person to say this by any means but if
you believe that abortion is murder and
they overturn roe v wade or like let's
just say for the the most draconian
thing happened right they said no more
if you have a an abortion should that
woman be tried for murder
what i was going to say or should the
doctor be the doctor that's what the
doctors the doctor's the hit man the one
who calls out the head is the woman and
the guy it has no say he has no seed at
the table lady because he has no uterus
so it's really on the woman who makes
the final decision whether or not that
that kid lives or dies who you know okay
so the doctor's an accomplice let's just
say but but the person who calls that
out if you call a hit out on somebody
and they kill him you're still on the
hook for that murder as well because
it's pre-meditated accomplice but right
now like they're even saying that the
six uh six weeks ahead is not enough for
them to decide and if a doctor has to
make the decision to get rid of the to
have an abortion or it's going to kill
the mother let's say if you want to go
that argument the doctor made the
decision not necessarily the woman so
now there's an argument well are doctors
going to go to trial for murder like
because there's no the doctor the doctor
is not making the choice the woman is
making the truth no like let's say the
woman wants to keep the baby but she's
about to die
and the doctor says should we let her
live or the baby
what do you think
should the woman i don't know the life
of the mother i don't know this isn't
those are very rare occasions but i
would also say this is like right now is
the way the law stands is if you kill a
pregnant woman you're on the hook for
two yeah that's true
right i know but this does happen a lot
where they're like it's not a small
percentage like women will have like
sepsis it's actually like a larger
amount somebody just went to jail
because they allowed the or they saved
the mom and not the baby
so um
[Music]